As a podcast listener, you may already be integrated in the world of media technology, but psychologists are continuously trying to figure out how and why people use devices like smartphones or activity trackers. These devices monitor our moods, our activity, and they can spur more engagement with others. In this episode, we speak with one psychologist who applies psychological science to interactive and mobile media technology, an area of research that is constantly changing, as the platforms become more sophisticated and much more interactive.
作为播客听众，您可能已经融入了媒体技术的世界，但心理学家们一直在试图弄清楚人们如何以及为何使用智能手机或活动追踪器等设备。这些设备监测我们的情绪、活动，并能激发我们与他人更多的互动。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位将心理科学应用于交互式和移动媒体技术的心理学家，随着平台变得越来越复杂和更具互动性，这一研究领域也在不断变化。
I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is Speaking of Psychology. Pamela Rutledge is director of the Media Psychology Research Center, and she teaches and designs media psychology courses at Fielding Graduate University. She is also active as a consultant, speaker, and researcher on applying psychological science to interactive technology and social media. She is editor-in-chief of the online journal Media Psychology Review. Welcome, Dr. Rutledge. Oh, it's a pleasure to be here.
我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。帕梅拉·拉特利奇是媒体心理学研究中心主任，她在菲尔丁研究生大学教授并设计媒体心理学课程。她还作为顾问、演讲者和研究员，活跃在将心理科学应用于交互技术和社交媒体的领域。她是在线期刊《媒体心理学评论》的主编。欢迎您，拉特利奇博士。哦，很高兴来到这里。
First of all, tell us a little bit about your area of expertise, which is media psychology. What does a media psychologist do and what do you do as director of the Media Psychology Research Center? Well, media psychology is fundamentally using the tools of psychology to think about media and technologies. So it's really using that in an applied way. And at the Media Psychology Research Center, we work with a number of media projects applying the fundamentals of psychology to help companies and organizations and even individuals understand how to better design, develop, and teach about media and technology. There's a lot of interest in how new technologies are affecting our behavior.
首先，请向我们介绍一下您的专业领域，即媒体心理学。媒体心理学家是做什么的？作为媒体心理学研究中心的主任，您的工作内容是什么？嗯，媒体心理学从根本上说是利用心理学工具来思考媒体和技术。所以它确实是以一种应用的方式在使用这些工具。在媒体心理学研究中心，我们与许多媒体项目合作，应用心理学基础知识来帮助公司、组织甚至个人了解如何更好地设计、开发和教授媒体与技术。人们对新技术如何影响我们的行为非常感兴趣。
Steve here, one of the producers of the podcast. He wears his Fitbit every day. I see you have one as well. And he competes with other people to get the greatest number of steps. So in a study of one, this would seem to indicate he's improving his health with this technology. Is this something psychologists are studying, using to monitor people's behaviors and how so? Yes, it is.
这是史蒂夫，播客的制作人之一。他每天都戴着Fitbit。我看到您也戴着一个。他会和其他人比赛，看谁走的步数最多。对于一个个体研究来说，这似乎表明他正在利用这项技术改善健康。这是心理学家正在研究并用于监测人们行为的内容吗？如果是，是如何监测的？是的，确实如此。
I mean, there's a lot of research going on right now, what we call the quantified self, where people are using wearable technologies to get information that they use to motivate themselves to make judgments about their performance. But a really critical part of this is the social connection. So there's a lot of competition. I wear the jawbone up, not the Fitbit, but my team includes my daughters. And so we're always comparing where did you walk, how much did you walk. And it's really fun to get a yay mom after you've done some exercising.
我的意思是，目前有很多研究正在进行，我们称之为“量化自我”，人们利用可穿戴技术获取信息，并利用这些信息来激励自己，对自己的表现做出判断。但其中一个非常关键的部分是社会联系。所以有很多竞争。我戴的是Jawbone Up，而不是Fitbit，但我的团队包括我的女儿们。所以我们总是会比较：你走了哪里，走了多少步。在锻炼之后听到一句“妈妈加油”，真的很有趣。
What about tracking people's moods, stepping away from exercising, but to moods? Smartphones track people's movements. And some researchers at Northwestern University were able to show that people who moved less during the day were more depressed or could be more depressed. How do you think smartphones are going to change how we track or monitor people's moods and mental health as we move forward? It won't just be smartphones that are changing. I think that it's going to be a lot more integration of technology. We have to remember that there really isn't a separation between our mind and our body. So it makes perfect sense that we would start tracking mood in addition to our physical behavior.
那么追踪人们的情绪呢？撇开锻炼不谈，转而谈论情绪。智能手机可以追踪人们的活动。西北大学的一些研究人员能够证明，白天活动较少的人更容易抑郁或可能更抑郁。您认为随着我们的前进，智能手机将如何改变我们追踪或监测人们情绪和心理健康的方式？改变的不仅仅是智能手机。我认为这将是技术的更多整合。我们必须记住，我们的身心之间并没有真正的分离。因此，我们开始在追踪身体行为的同时追踪情绪，这是完全合理的。
My colleague, Dr. Jerylind Hogg and I have just recently begun research with a product called Spire, which measures your breath as a way of recording your stress level. And that's integrated back into your steps and onto your phone. So it gives you indicators of are you moving and are you breathing and your relative stress level? And that's just one of many applications. And I think we're really at the forefront of these interesting applications that provide triggers to make behavior change. Do you think psychologists could use apps like these when looking for ways to help their clients? I don't know if that's anything that you study, but I'm just curious as to where do you take this?
我和我的同事杰琳·霍格博士最近刚开始研究一款名为Spire的产品，它通过测量呼吸来记录压力水平。这些数据会整合回你的步数并显示在手机上。它为你提供指标：你是否在运动，你的呼吸状况如何，以及你的相对压力水平。这只是众多应用中的一个。我认为我们确实处于这些提供触发因素以促进行为改变的有趣应用的前沿。您认为心理学家在寻找帮助客户的方法时可以使用这些应用程序吗？我不知道这是否是您研究的内容，但我只是好奇您会将此引向何方？
Well, I think you can take the knowledge a lot of ways. I mean, one is that it's very individually empowering. So people have now a new tool in their own arsenal to make change on their own behalf. But it's also a very effective way to work with clinicians, coaches, and therapists. An application that I've been using is the heart lab, or heart math, rather, which allows you to measure your heart rate in conjunction with your breathing as a mechanism for getting better mind-body coherence. So similar to meditation, but it's a way of showing your therapist the track record that you're keeping, and she can then work with you on the mental
嗯，我认为你可以从很多方面利用这些知识。我的意思是，一方面，它非常具有个人赋能作用。人们现在拥有了一个新的工具库，可以代表自己做出改变。但它也是与临床医生、教练和治疗师合作的一种非常有效的方式。我一直在使用的一个应用程序是Heart Lab，或者说是Heart Math，它允许你结合呼吸来测量心率，作为实现更好身心一致性的机制。这类似于冥想，但它是一种向你的治疗师展示你所保持的记录的方式，然后她可以与你一起处理心理
triggers that are disrupting your thought patterns, causing you stress, causing you distress, and the things that actually improve that. You've been a media psychologist for a while. I'm wondering, with all this new technology is coming out, and it seems like it's coming out constantly. Is it making your job more interesting or what you're able to learn and use the technology? Oh, absolutely. It makes it fascinating and it also makes it just, I'm absolutely able to justify the purchase of any piece of technology at all because I just tell my husband, oh honey, I have to study this. But sure, it does two things. One is that it keeps us very on the ball because we're continually figuring out what are the affordances or the attributes of any particular piece of
那些破坏你思维模式、导致你压力、导致你痛苦的触发因素，以及那些真正能改善这些状况的事物。您担任媒体心理学家已经有一段时间了。我想知道，随着所有这些新技术的出现，而且似乎它们不断涌现，这是否让您的工作变得更有趣，或者说您能够学习和使用这些技术？哦，当然。这让工作变得非常迷人，而且我也绝对能够为购买任何一件技术产品找到理由，因为我只需要告诉我的丈夫，哦亲爱的，我必须研究这个。但当然，它做了两件事。一是它让我们保持高度警觉，因为我们一直在弄清楚任何特定技术的赋能或属性是什么，
technology and how are we mapping that back to psychological theory? Because as you know, it's not really about the tools. It's about human behavior and emotions and how we're wired. And so if we understand those fundamentals, then we have the ability to evaluate all this new technology. The bad thing is, every semester I have to rewrite my syllabuses because I need to keep the content up to date. Yes. Overall, and this is, you hear this often in the media. You know, there's a sense that social media and emerging technologies are changing people,
以及我们如何将其映射回心理学理论？因为如你所知，这实际上与工具无关。它关乎人类的行为、情绪以及我们的思维方式。因此，如果我们理解了这些基本原理，我们就有能力评估所有这些新技术。糟糕的是，每个学期我都必须重写我的教学大纲，因为我需要保持内容更新。是的。总的来说，你在媒体中经常听到这一点。你知道，有一种感觉是社交媒体和新兴技术正在改变人们，
making them more narcissistic, self-involved. You know, you said that you think they are making people more empathetic and responsible for other people's well-being. Can you explain why you think that? Can you give some examples? I believe that people are becoming more empathetic because this connectivity and social media are allowing them to see other people globally. in a way that they've never been able to see before.
使他们变得更加自恋、以自我为中心。你知道，你说过你认为它们正在使人们变得更有同理心，并对其他人的福祉负责。你能解释一下为什么你这么认为吗？你能举一些例子吗？我相信人们正在变得更有同理心，因为这种连接性和社交媒体让他们能够以一种前所未有的方式在全球范围内看到其他人。
I know a lot of people are worried about things like narcissism, but I think that's overstated. What is important is that people understand the benefits of technology and where they need to establish limits. You know, offline, we have all these patterns of behavior that we know how to take care of ourselves, self-care, but we now have to learn how to do this in this new environment. We have to extend our living space, so to speak,
我知道很多人担心像自恋这样的事情，但我认为这被夸大了。重要的是人们要了解技术的益处以及他们需要在哪里设定限制。你知道，在现实生活中，我们有所有这些我们知道如何照顾自己的行为模式，即自我保健，但我们现在必须学习如何在这一新环境中做到这一点。我们可以说，我们必须扩展我们的生活空间，
into the online arena. So we have to learn how to set online boundaries. We have to learn how to respond to things. The Red Cross was able to raise $5 million within 24 hours after the Haitian earthquake. That's an extraordinary amount of participation. Now, while some people might have referred to that as slackivism saying that they're not really involved, the fact that people have that awareness that they were willing to participate in that small bit means that they're going to be much more sensitive to future calls
进入在线领域。所以我们必须学习如何设定在线边界。我们必须学习如何回应事物。海地地震后，红十字会在24小时内筹集了500万美元。那是一笔非凡的参与金额。现在，虽然有些人可能称之为“懒人行动主义”，说他们并没有真正参与，但人们拥有那种意识，即他们愿意参与那一点点，意味着他们对未来的呼吁会更加敏感，
so that they're aware of other people in need, and they'll be much more liable to help. It also empowers the giver, because now there are all these kinds of ways where people can make a difference in very small ways. That sense of agency is going to make people much more willing to participate. So I think this idea that everyone has become totally self-focused is exactly wrong. So I think that we have a misconception of,
这样他们就会意识到其他人有需要，并且他们会更有可能提供帮助。它也赋予了捐赠者权力，因为现在有各种各样的方式让人们可以通过非常微小的方式做出改变。那种能动性的感觉将使人们更愿意参与。所以我认为这种每个人都变得完全以自我为中心的想法是完全错误的。所以我认为我们对技术的危险存在误解，
the dangers of technology. That's not to say there aren't problems. There are. It's important to have training. But we don't want to overstate the problems because we don't want to miss the benefits, because there's tremendous upside. Well, Dr. Rutledge, thank you so much for joining us. This was a fascinating conversation.
这并不是说没有问题。确实有。进行培训很重要。但我们不想夸大问题，因为我们不想错过好处，因为这里有巨大的上升空间。好吧，拉特利奇博士，非常感谢您加入我们。这是一次引人入胜的谈话。
It's my pleasure. For more information on Dr. Rutledge's work and to hear more episodes, please go to our website, speaking of psychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是我的荣幸。有关拉特利奇博士工作的更多信息以及收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。与美国心理学会一起，《心理学谈话》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。